it's time for roses and Rose Day oh my
gosh The Bachelor premiered you guys
first roses and Rose a of the season and
I can't even have Rose a because I'm
sick but I am doped up on a lot of meds
so pretty much the same I am ill but the
bachelor is alive and well Nick vial
here to please here to steam here for
all of us to get some Nick that's right
the episode started out with a montage
of Nick's shirtless running through
chilly Chicago and we even got a shower
shot dang Nick did promise us that the
season would get see me could hits
literally take a shower think so Nick
acknowledged that yes is a little weird
he's the bachelor and my favorite part
he acknowledged that he mumbles yeah
you're here for
Thank You Nick speak up then we recaps
the heartbreak and realized how
incredibly different Nick used to look
when he was on Andy and Caitlin's
seasons
protip throw a beard do some push-ups
and you won't be The Bachelor then we
meet the ladies but I'm only gonna go
for my favorites because there's so many
we're gonna lose a lot of them at the
end of this episode
let's meet Rachel Rachel is a 31 year
old attorney from Dallas here's why I
love her
well-spoken gorgeous old enough for Nick
here's why I'm questioning her
what is this vacuum Rachel girl you're
an attorney making money
dancer on your living room maybe get a
vacuum it wasn't invented in 1975 okay
she'll learn how to be on camera then we
had Danielle Danielle is 27 and owns a
Ferrari nail salons from everything nick
has told ET exclusively he needs a
confident lady and again I think
danielle has her stuff together then we
meet the Italian Vanessa Grimaldi I
don't know what that accent was German
Italian she says Italian Italian so what
we're already learning from vanessa is
we're all saying it wrong I guess but
gorgeous accomplished studious yes just
what Nick needs he's 36
but again Nick promised us a steamy
season so we gotta have some steamy
girls and they are corinne and liz purse
we meet corinne who runs a multi-million
dollar company by writing emails and
making phone calls and still lives with
a nanny okay Corinne
very sexual later in the episode we'll
get to it and then we meet Liz who
acknowledges that she had a one-night
stand with Nick at Jade and Tanner's
wedding last January but she wouldn't
allow him to get her number and she
never contacted him again
dang Liz doesn't even think Nick's gonna
remember her sounds like a night and
last we have the girl in a dolphin shark
costume whose name I don't remember but
she was hilarious yes her entrance was
her literally wearing a shark costume
which she called a dolphin costume and
she said she's an aspiring dolphin
trainer and she made this amazing pun
hey definitely can't wait to talk to you
more inside what I liked about it too
was that the other ladies were really
supportive of her hilarious 'ti for a
show that's so much about catfights it's
nice to see some friendships on the
first night except of course for Corinne
who had some trash talk to me which
indicates to me she's probably gonna be
our villain okay so whatever dolphin
girl's name is I mean she took this to
the max she went in the pool and Nick
made this a very funny comment shark she
thinks she's a dolphin that's a concern
so so far funny steamy I love it and
then Liz and Nick acknowledge their past
and Nick is a little harsh I was
actually in the freezing cold at a
bachelor premiere watch party last night
which and talked to Jay who is Liz's
good friend Liz her maid of honor and
Jade said she wishes Nick had treated
her better so Nick didn't take that very
well in fact he like literally left the
conversation all right rose time Rachel
gets the first impression rose yes good
choice Vanessa gets the first rose yes
good choice and these choices often
indicate who Nick will end up having a
serious connection with first
impressions everything right not for
Nick what time's a charm
and Liz bum-bum-bum gets the last rose
he made her pay he still gave her a rose
we need the drama what am i doing and
Corinne got a rose too
and oh my god memorize that curtain was
gonna get sexual well she really really
really did in the sneak peak for the
whole season
I'm going to have sex with them it's
just gonna be magical
my heart is gold but my regime is
platinum platinum interesting I don't
have my gemstones very well should it
have been diamond it's platinum better
than gold whatever guys we will be here
recapping the bachelor every week and I
promise I will have some actual Rose a
ASAP because I need it like I need an IV
of vitamin C right now please subscribe
to etz youtube channel check out ET
online calm like us on facebook where we
have lots of bachelor alumni interviews
and follow me on twitter snapchat
Instagram Newport
[Music]